good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i'm
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2021 2022 foundations biomedical
data science seminar series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence and biomedicine where we
enjoy presentations on fridays from
leading thinkers about the promise
opportunities and the hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences
selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program will
help we'll leverage these presentations
as vital material for our culminating
in-person grant project
workshop to be held here in historic
charlottesville virginia next june
it is my delight and honor today to
welcome our speaker dr caitlin wiley
from the university of virginia
caitlin received her phd from cambridge
university and she is here at the
university of virginia's school of
engineering and applied sciences
where she is an assistant professor uh
as a social scientist she investigates
the ways in which people create
interpret data design research tools
techniques and construct knowledge in
the sciences and engineering she uses
interviews and participant observations
to study overlooked collaborators on
research teams such as technicians
students and volunteers and she teaches
engineering students how to assess the
social and ethical dimensions of the
technology and professional work they
are doing so they can be
designed as safely equitably and
successfully in terms of socio socio
technical systems uh
as safely as possible
we are proud to say that caitlyn is also
serving as one of our 2021 2021-2022
biomedical data science innovation lab
mentors and caitlin's lecture today is
entitled ethical ai requires ethical
collaboration collaboration being a
crucial part of science and yet
respectful knowledgeable
and integration is a challenge to
achieve and in her talk she's going to
discuss the frameworks for thinking
about research as a collective endeavor
and practical strategies for supporting
ethical team science including how to
craft group identity how to foster an
inclusive environment and how to
translate knowledge across disciplines
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube and
if you are watching on youtube thank you
so much for joining us today and also
our specially selected
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for
caitlyn via the chat feature in their
zoom sessions i will personally
synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of her lecture
and without further ado we welcome
caitlin thank you so much caitlin we are
super excited to hear from you today
thanks jack thanks everyone
yeah as jack said i really want to make
a broader argument than ai in particular
and you could replace ai in this title
with research or science or technology
in the sense that we can't do anything
we can't make any ethical products
without an ethical process
and so i want to make the argument that
a crucial part of ethical research
process is collaboration
and so in this photo and that's me in
the middle in the green jacket i'm being
an ethnographer
in a research lab in the field of
vertebrate paleontology
so that's you might think that's pretty
different from ai and medical research
i'm going to
disagree and suggest what we can learn
from a variety of fields that can inform
how we can build ethical ai together
across disciplines across cultures
so in this photo there are scientists
there are technicians there are
volunteers
there's a social scientist right there's
various things with which people make
knowledge about
extinct animals
and so i want to think about
collaboration in terms of
a broader sense of who is doing the
research not just the scientists not
just the pis but really everybody in the
room
so first of all let's think a little bit
about what we mean by collaboration
i'm sure you've seen some of these words
they're very trendy especially among
funders
um
and i want to think about yeah my
scientists and engineer collaborators
get caught up on like what the
differences are between these words
i think that's less important than the
assumptions behind these words
so let's think about what it means to be
interdisciplinary transdisciplinary
multidisciplinary
it assumes that everyone belongs to a
discipline
which is not always true right as
someone who does
science technology and society as a
field and i belong to a lot of
disciplines and the idea that we are
working across them
suggests that we already belong to one
okay so there are limitations with that
view
these terms also assume that everyone is
separate okay we are co-producing so
again the idea that disciplines are
separate bodies of knowledge and of
people
and that can be a barrier by assuming
that these disciplines and groups of
people actually don't overlap already
and then finally these words and
especially their trendiness right the
nsf is very pro-convergence research for
example
and
it assumes that science is not already
an extremely collaborative endeavor
and so that made me wonder like who
who counts then as a collaborator who
are we assuming is a collaborator when
we take these frameworks of convergence
and co-production and cross-cutting
initiatives
what is new about them
so generally
if we're asking who we consider to be
collaborators these are the groups
so scientists or or people like me
researchers have have great respect for
other people with phds and so you
generally would count them as
collaborators
technicians varies a lot by field in
some fields of biomedicine technicians
have phds and are authors on
publications and other fields like
vertebrate paleontology
technicians do not have a shared
credential some of them don't have a
college degree
they are not considered authors on
papers and their work is considered to
be very separate from the research
itself so this is a disciplinary
difference that can get in the way of
interdisciplinary collaborations
and then of course students are a really
interesting example because everyone
thinks it's good to have students
involved in research
but whether they're seen as learners or
as collaborators
differs a lot based on the context and
on the discipline so sometimes you you
see professors sort of tempting students
to join their labs
so that the students can have a paper so
they can be an author on a paper sort of
someday
after putting in years of effort and if
they contribute enough
epistemic you know intellectual
material to that paper and so how you
define that is really squishy and hard
to
standardize
and the same goes for volunteers so some
fields of research rely on citizen
scientists or amateurs
paleontology is one of them
and yet rarely are they considered
contributors in the same way that
students or technicians or especially
researchers are
um instead they're considered kind of an
outreach effort or maybe like free labor
that's kind of nice but not actually
contributing knowledge and that's wrong
as i'm going to show you through some
examples
and then finally research participants
are not considered collaborators
generally they're considered like the
subjects of the research which is not a
very fair way to think about them
and of course community members so all
the rest of us who are around these
research projects or even living in the
site of research projects
um
we are usually considered the context
the background
not part of the research team
and so i'm going to challenge some of
these assumptions and ask us to think
more broadly about who we should
consider collaborators by looking at
these particular
categories of collaborators
through some examples from my research
so basically my argument is if we
recognize how all of these people
contribute to scientific research we'll
learn a lot about how diverse
perspectives and experiences help us
make sense of the world together right
do better research
and how we can do that better
and so i would suggest that there's a
moral argument to this more inclusive
view of collaborators
um and there's a practical argument that
we will make better knowledge when we
work together
so here are some theories i want to
think with i use these a lot across
various projects that i work on
the first is a community of practice and
so this is the idea that we define a
community based on the work that they do
their their practice their shared
efforts as opposed to their disciplinary
identity or their credentials
because this is more focused on the work
and less focused on
the past
okay so it acknowledges that people can
have awesome expertise that they bring
to the table regardless of
what degrees they have
and so this has this theory relies on a
notion of learning that is in situ
sort of an apprenticeship model of
learning social norms and technical
practice which i think is very true
in cutting edge research when you know
nobody knows how to build ethical ai and
so we're all learning how to do it
together from each other by doing it
another theory i work with a lot is
called standpoint theory this comes from
feminist thought
and it's the idea that if we're all
standing in a valley
you know our geographic standpoint our
perspective is different from everyone
else's nobody can share the same view of
this valley that we're overlooking
and therefore it's valuable to have
people standing around a problem if you
think of it that way
because they're all going to bring
different experiences different ways of
understanding that problem
physically a different perspective right
based on their identities and what their
lives have been like
and this diversity enriches knowledge
makes knowledge better to have a variety
of inputs
and then finally
there's a lovely way of thinking about
expertise that points out that those you
know an insular team a community of
practice that ignores outsiders
um is missing out on all of the wisdom
that comes from being an outsider okay
we all get a little narrow in our in our
perspectives when we're with people who
are doing the same things as us
or people we've worked with a long time
and we forget to consider
what it's like to look at our team from
the outside and so atn wenger calls this
a wisdom of peripherality okay so the
wisdom that comes from being outside of
a community of practice and i think
that's incredibly important for ethical
ai in particular because the
implications of it are going to be broad
and therefore we need to have outsiders
right supposedly non-experts like
community members
and we need their perspectives
all right so how do we learn about
ethical collaboration
by looking at the kinds of collaborators
that we often overlook so
as jack said i am an ethnographer i use
participant observation and interviews
in my research so that means i hang out
in research communities and talk to
people about what it's like to do their
work
and the three cases i'm going to talk
about today are technicians in
vertebrate paleontology
undergrads who work in engineering labs
um and community members who partner
with my research team to study the
effects of climate change on their
infrastructure in their town in alaska
all right so let's start with those
technicians
the way that scientists think about
technicians genst tends to be
in two veins one is
they're part of the machine
okay they're part of the laboratory
equipment
as you can see from some of these quotes
and the technicians the value of
technicians is being able to be
replicable they just need to do the
experiment in a way that other people
can
achieve the same results
um
so this is one way okay this is sort of
grunt work they're very technical
they're just meant to follow
instructions
and yet if you've ever done research you
know this is deeply untrue that often
it's the technicians who are the only
ones who know how to make that machine
give the results that you want or the
only ones who know how to fix
something when things go wrong
and
and so this sort of mechanical view of
technicians is really ignoring their
expertise and so the image on the right
is
a fossil preparator holding a tiny drill
so the thing she's holding is vibrating
and it's removing the rock
from this gorgeous fish fossil
and you can imagine like how on earth
could this be mechanical the level of
artistry it takes to
remove a very thin layer of rock without
damaging the bones underneath
and
is incredible
and has nothing to do with being part of
the machine
so this sort of dismissive view of
technicians
is not only wrong but offensive
and so the other way that scientists
tend to view technicians and this is how
they talk about them right scientists
know that their work relies on the value
of their technicians the expertise of
their technicians they just don't talk
about it in formal senses like in papers
in some fields
um
but scientists know
and so they say things that like that
technicians have lab hands or instinct
okay there's something unnameable to
their skill
that is very um
hands-on
skill based rather than
credential
based so yeah for vertebrate
paleontology in particular fossil
preparators talk a lot about creative
problem solving that their work really
isn't is an endless stream of problems
that they have to um approach so like
every fossil is individual
every kind of rock is a little bit
different every tool is going to work
differently on every rock and so
there's a lot of creativity and problem
solving and tinkering and tool design
that makes their work possible of making
the fossil visible
visible for the scientist to study
and so if you've read hope jaron's 2016
bestseller lab girl
it's about her
career as a paleobotanist and it's
really um a love letter to her
technician bill
whom she takes with her across various
institutions throughout her academic
career because she knows that her
research and her success as a professor
depend on bill's expertise and support
and friendship and so i thought that was
a wonderful sort of best-selling
memoir view of the actual role of
technicians in research
i wrote a whole book about technicians
this book is not actually about
dinosaurs as you as may be confusing
from the title
and this is available open access on the
mit press website if you want to know
more about
how to think about creativity and manual
skills in research
all right so let's think about
undergrads
so
universities tout undergraduate research
we all think it's good right it's an
inherent good
it's got to be good for students
and part of this comes from a
perspective of professionalization and
training and developing lab skills
through learning by doing
learning in a community of practice
and this is evident in the way that the
nsf for example portrays research
experiences for undergraduates or reu
programs as educational grants they're
not research grants
which is interesting because it's really
paying a student to work in the lab for
a summer
and so i found in my studies of
engineering labs that actually
undergrads are contributing a lot
to the knowledge and social community
and and learning
of lab communities okay they're not just
sort of passive recipients of what it's
like to be in a lab which you know
they're learning that too but they're
also contributing back in ways that are
not recognized and are actually amazing
and so let me tell you some examples
so in one summer for one summer a
biomedical engineer was placed in an
electrical engineering lab she was not
happy about this she felt very out of
place
and she didn't really know anything
about electrical engineering
except that this lab was building
sensors to try to measure stress in in
patients
and so the pi of the lab was saying to
the lab group of you know 15 to 20
students in a room he was saying how can
we measure
stress
you know what about cortisol can we
measure cortisol like he doesn't know
he's either he's an electrical engineer
and the undergrad says well no cortisol
is not a good indicator of stress
because it changes over the course of
the day it changes based on what the
person is doing it's not a reliable
indicator of whether the person is
experiencing stress
and the pi in the whole room shuts up to
hear this undergrad explain this because
they don't know
okay she's bringing knowledge from
another field
she's bringing knowledge from her broad
education as an undergrad as opposed to
grad students and pis who have become
very narrow become very specialized
and she was opening back up
and engineering knowledge for them
another example was from a student um
who was part of a robotics club and so
he learned how to 3d print parts for
this robotics club and he also worked in
a research lab and the lab was building
sensors that were going to be put
outside and they were trying to debate
how to protect the sensors
and the students said well why don't we
3d print a casing
and they were like can we do that
and so the student ended up designing
and printing the casings for these
sensors that were the basis of the
research lab's research
so it's an incredible contribution not
only of like an idea that came from
outside the lab but also the skills to
know how to do it because no one
no one else in the lab knew how to 3d
print anything and then when that
student left
graduated it was interesting because the
lab really scrambled because they didn't
have anyone to replace those skills
and then finally undergrads play this
really interesting role
in engineering research labs and
universities um
in the sense that they
get really good at particular things so
again this grunt work idea of
technicians and students washing
glassware you know doing repetitive
experiments
um
and that that's boring and easy and
therefore the more junior people in the
lab should do it
and yet undergrads would become so good
at these supposedly menial tasks that
the results would be better
okay so later on down the research
process the results were better when a
particular undergrad prepared the
reagent
and and then
that re when that skill was recognized
or when that contribution was recognized
and
pis would sometimes say to grad students
or to other students you know go and
learn that technique from this undergrad
because they really do it well
so in that sense undergrads are taking
this skill this task that is supposedly
boring and routine and easy and and
making visible the expertise that it
relies on and they're then passing on
that knowledge to other people in the
lab so they're creating
learning opportunities for the grad
students for the pi
and then finally i've seen lots of
examples of undergrads
coming up with ways that their research
teams could use their methods and for
other applications
so for example the in the electrical
engineering lab they are really great at
building low-cost sensors
and so usually they do these for
healthcare purposes and like patient
monitoring purposes and one undergrad
said well why don't we use them for air
pollution monitoring you know we already
measure indoor environments
why couldn't we just put one on a stop
light put a sensor system on a stop
light and use it to predict
asthma risk for example based on the
quality of the air
and everybody else in the lab thought
this was brilliant like what a great
idea
okay so again this undergrad ability to
think big and think outside of what
might be expected within a particular
lab or a particular discipline
and
it's this is real intellectual
contribution
and so i want to talk a little more
about how undergrads create space for
others to learn because again we assume
that undergrads are the learners here
and actually in my research i'm finding
that they are not the only learners when
an undergrad is present everybody else
learns a lot more
and part of that is because undergrads
are expected to be learners so they can
ask supposedly dumb questions right that
no one expects them to know how things
work
but most of the time i see undergrads
ask questions in in lab meetings for
example all the grad students become
really quiet
because they want to know the answer
okay and they might have too much
in you know too much in the game too
much skin in the game they don't want
their pi to know that they don't
actually know how that machine works or
why that result looks that way or why we
make graphs in this way
and so undergrads reopen these
assumptions in ways that are really
helpful for the graduate students in
particular
also i've seen undergrads ask questions
about how things work that then the
researchers pause and say
i don't know why we do things this way
let's try your way
right or i don't know why
this is obviously data this reading and
this one is obviously noise i'm going to
reject this one and i'm it's really hard
for me to explain to you why
and i've seen researchers really sit
down for a few minutes and like
analyze their own assumptions and this
reflective work is going to make the
research better
it's making the practitioners slow down
and think through what they're doing so
that they can explain it to the
undergrad
and that's going to make them more
responsible more careful in their
research
and then finally
many professors use undergrads as judges
for grad students conference talks for
example like
grad students are often practicing talks
learning how to give presentations in
group meetings
um and at the end the pis will turn to
the undergrads and say like how did that
go for you
how well did you understand that
because they
value the undergrads perspective as a
general listener right they're not the
undergrads are not expected to be an
expert in that field and the grad
students are supposed to be talking at
an audience level that's probably about
equivalent to an undergrad
because people in the audience at the
conference will be experts in various
different things
and so undergrads are considered sort of
the ideal audience for practice talks
which i think is really interesting
and so in that sense it's sort of
valuing the undergrads ignorance
in a way
okay the undergrads ability to
understand
what is comprehensible what is clear
about that explanation
as opposed to somebody who already
understands the field and assumes that
they know
so this is an image a photo of
this grad student
with the purple gloves the machine
wasn't working right
this is a machine that saws samples in
material science
and the undergrad was saying
um
what's wrong like is it supposed to work
like this and the graduate student
stopped and had to like take it all
apart to figure out why it was working
the way that it was and what the problem
was and so both of them got to learn how
that machine worked
really because the undergrad said you
know should it be making that noise
[Music]
and then of course undergrads offer the
opportunity for others to learn how to
mentor how to collaborate how to
communicate
because you know the undergrads are
around they need someone to sort of
watch over them and so grad students and
professors learn by doing in that sense
and they couldn't do that if the
undergrads were not there
and then a lot of grad students and
professors talk about undergrads as
motivating that they're the undergrads
are so happy to be there and they're
really excited about the research
and that the grad students feel sort of
uplifted and even the pis will say it's
so fun when so and so student comes to
lab meetings because they bring a lot of
energy
so my argument here is that undergrads
are not the only learners in these
communities and that really everybody
benefits when we include students and
research teams
for the students intellectual
contributions for their contributions of
skillful labor
and for their
ignorance
basically their broad education their
lack of specialization their lack of
assumptions about a particular field
and that those are really helpful for
helping the experts think through what
they're doing and explain what they're
doing
okay finally so
community members are
a really interesting case in the ethics
of collaboration because
sort of the field of community based
research and community engaged research
is growing
in really interesting ways
so i think i think we can all see
arguments for why technicians and
students should be considered
collaborators for their sort of classic
epistemic contributions
and community community members is a
little harder it's a little harder for
us to understand
so let me talk you through a case in
which our research um will be a complete
failure
if we cannot collaborate ethically
responsibly effectively
with community members
so i'm on a team um
that got an nsf award through the
navigating the new arctic program which
is one of the nsf's 10 big ideas if
you've been following the nsf's um
research
sort of priorities
and the goal is to study an urban
setting and to see how climate change is
interacting with infrastructure built
infrastructure
urban
we're studying utkahvic alaska
which is the northernmost city in the
united states you can see at the top of
this map it's that red dot to the very
tip of alaska
and on the north slope there's about
four thousand people there
who live there um they're majority
indigenous alaska native
um
and to to understand how their
infrastructure is being affected by
climate change and and the reverse how
the local environments are being
affected by the infrastructure that
they've built
we absolutely rely on them
not only are they living
you know with that infrastructure day in
and day out
and they also are drawing on about
twelve thousand years worth of human
occupation at utk
and so
lots of indigenous knowledge lots of
traditional knowledge lots of just a
massive archive of climate knowledge and
how to adapt to it
so we are showing up with the machines
in this photo this is my collaborator
matthew joel who's in uva's architecture
school
and he's building a sensor tower with
some students
in charlottesville
and this sensor tower has all kinds of
micro meteorological sensors so
that can measure precipitation and
temperature and solar radiation and lots
of other things
and so the idea is we're going to plant
these at various points in new chaotic
to
observe what happens between
infrastructure and the local environment
over the next five years
and so we are a team of environmental
scientists and architects and social
scientists
and you can see i put the the residents
of kyogre on our author list
because we can't do this without them
and really we're doing this for them we
hope to get knowledge for environmental
science and social science and
architecture but really our hope is to
study how infrastructure and the
environment interacts so that we can
give some design guidelines to the city
of ukayogvik
in terms of where they should develop
where they should build where is the
permafrost most stable which design of
housing best resists the wind
um
how can we best
build structures to prevent coastal
erosion right utk is right on the ocean
so yeah we this is this project in
service of them um
and we also hope that
all of our fields will learn from it too
so let's talk a little bit about arctic
climate change
so ukiyoga is in the arctic circle and
and this is what happens when permafrost
thaws
you can see that the road on the left is
all wavy
roads in alaska are mostly built on
gravel not cement because the ground
moves so much that the gravel is more
sort of forgiving
and but still this is a dangerous road
and especially if it changes enough that
it opens up
a chasm a pothole and it's really unsafe
particularly when there's ice which is
most of the year newt kyogrik
also structures start to fail because
the ground underneath them is is
softening right thawing away and then
this is what the ground looks like when
permafrost thaws and all the water that
was locked into frozen soil and also all
the carbon
um is released when that permafrost
thaws and so then we get these very
weird called thermocarce
very weird geological formations that
are tough to build on
and water moves in unexpected ways so
there's issues with flooding there's
issues with salt water coming into the
fresh water ponds that ukiyogik uses for
drinking water
so lots of infrastructural issues
throughout the city
also another issue that the arctic has
that most of us
don't you know have the privilege of not
worrying about is oil pipelines
so there are a lot of pipelines in
alaska and also in siberia in the
siberian arctic so here's
um
here's here's okay big
and so
one of the main problems with permafrost
thaw is that pipelines can become
broken or unstable and then there can be
fires
this has been a major problem across
siberia and across alaska
so here are some ways in which the
community is already adapting as i said
um people have lived in newt kyogvik for
over 12 000 years
so they have deep expertise about how to
survive in this arctic climate
um
except that it's changing faster than it
ever has before so we're learning a lot
our team is learning a lot about
resilience and cultural resilience
from um
especially the indigenous members and
the indigenous residents of kyogre
and so for example
this picture on the right is the utk
coastline
you can see the beach there's the arctic
ocean
gorgeous
gorgeous city
um and so okiyagik used to be a major
oiling
oil center for the united states there
used to be a lot of money newt gingrich
as a result
um and so these are old
rail cars
you can kind of see that these are rail
cars buried in the sand and this is to
prevent coastal erosion caused by sea
level rise
all right so that the ocean stays on
that side
of these train cars to protect the city
which is on the other side
so what an amazing example of reuse and
making do with what you have because
kyogre
is remote it's hard to get things there
you have to fly basically all supplies
in by airplane
it's very expensive and so they took
basically trash right and
these abandoned rail cars probably from
the oil boom
and repurpose them as a way to hold
their beach in place
brilliant
and then on the left are pictures of our
team um
deploying ground penetrating radar
beneath the house in kyogre so all the
houses all this building in new kyogvik
are
sort of five or so feet off the ground
to try to keep them warmer right you
don't want to build right on permafrost
because it'll suck all the heat out of
your house
and
and so we're spending a lot of time
crawling beneath people's property
with ground penetrating radar lines and
to measure the the permafrost below and
see where is rock where is ice
and again people are very concerned
about their houses collapsing
again the cost of living is very high in
kyogrik and people cannot afford um to
pick up their house and move it right or
to build a new foundation because the
foundation is melting
so this is very much like
how do we help them now situation as
well as how do we plan for future
changes caused by climate change
so again this is this is a moral
argument and an epistemic one
so it is more ethical to work with
communities in all cases than to assume
that we are serving them or acting in
their interest right nothing about us
without us from the disability justice
movement
applies to all communities
um and of course people who live in
ukiyogik have sovereignty over their
knowledge their indigenous knowledge
their traditional knowledge their
experiential knowledge their expertise
right of living in this climate
and they have sovereignty over their
land particularly indigenous sovereignty
and
the movement and data ethics is towards
indigenous sovereignty over their data
so that means that any data that we
collect on their land on residents land
belongs to them and not to us
and so this seems sort of obvious when
you put it that way but it's very
different from the previous research
traditions where scientists show up do a
bunch of measurements and leave right
and
and leave nothing behind for residents
don't produce
knowledge that the residents can use
sometimes don't even share their results
with residents
or they're studying science just for
science's sake rather than
for anything that would be useful to
living in the arctic
and so our team is facing really
interesting challenges about how to
respect indigenous data sovereignty how
to collect data that are useful for
people who live there and accessible not
only because the internet access is very
challenging
but also comprehensible right if we
don't have a lot of data scientists
living in ukiyog how do we make this
data relevant for them how can we
display it for example what kind of
dashboard
of temperatures across the city might be
useful for them
and of course this is particularly hard
to do because eud kyogre is very
overstudied
it has an airport so basically all
people who are studying the american
arctic do studies in new cayogic just
because it's more accessible than some
of the more remote villages
and so there's a long history of
exploitation by scientists
so what we call parachute science where
people arrive
take their samples take their data
sometimes they take social science data
like interviews with people who live
there
and then they disappear
okay so again if we're arguing that the
indigenous sovereignty of land extends
to data this is a serious moral and
ethical and responsibility and
you know mistake
so we need to overcome those challenges
first of all the history of exploitation
and crucially we can do better science
with the community members help
and so for example we are really
interested in permafrost
characterization so that means like what
is the permafrost made of is it mostly
soil is it mostly water is it rock
and how do we understand that what what
can we actually see with the ground
penetrating radar data
and our collaborators in new kyogre who
are various um
civil organizations as well as some
individual sort of residents private
residents
they said well we don't really care
about that but what we'd really like to
know is how do we save our ice sellers
so utki avec is a wailing culture and
they collect whales in the fall in the
spring and store them in ice cellars
which our sellers dug into the
permafrost
and they've been doing it this for
thousands of years and the ice sellers
are now thawing along with the
permafrost
and so the whale meat is spoiling and
this is not only a loss for subsistence
living
and which most people know kyogrik
and practice subsistence whaling and
subsistence hunting and gathering
and
the loss of the ice cellar is also a
major cultural blow because the whale is
a crucial part of the sort of world view
of
the anupiak culture
and ice sellers are considered to be the
whale's home on land so the whale gives
themselves to
the whalers the whalers take the whale
home to the ice seller
and so if the ice seller is thawing
it's a disaster it's a sign of
disrespect to that whale
and so there's intense cultural loss
in these sort of apparently simple forms
of infrastructure and so then we so we
tried to change our research question to
be more about
what is it about permafrost that
preserves meat
because the the town of hokkyog bought
some sort of industrial deep freezers
and put whale meat in there and they
said it doesn't taste as good
it doesn't work it doesn't meet the
cultural sort of significance of the ice
sellers
there's something chemical that's
happening in them not just
freezing it's not just about temperature
and so that's actually a really
fascinating question scientifically as
well as with deep cultural meaning
for our partners
in new chaotic
another instance in which we are reliant
on their expertise is trying to decide
where we're going to put all of our
sensors and where we should do ground
penetrating radar surveys
which really relies on
asking the residents where have you seen
the ground move
where have you seen flooding
whose house is crooked okay those are
all indicators that they know
and that can help us decide where we can
watch the most things happen
and it's sort of horrible to sort of
watch someone's house fall down
and but again the hope is that we'll
learn from that failure
how to build better how to build
structures that are going to be more
resilient
and of course our our
residents our partners have a very
challenging role to play which is to
stop us when we're wrong
and so we showed up you know saying
we're going to bring ground penetrating
radar we're going to do these surveys of
the permafrost to tell you where it's
safe to build
and
isn't this great
and they said
you know we have 12 000 years worth of
archaeology underneath us
you can't run ground penetrating radar
over our sacred sites
so thank goodness right thank goodness
they were kind enough and respectful
enough to stop us and to tell us where
those sites are
because we certainly don't want to do
them any harm right
and
or do them any disrespect and so we
would have done bad science we would
have done
offensive insulting science
without their guidance and they didn't
have to do that right they could have
just said no
instead they said we have this concern
here's a map
avoid these areas
which is going to make our research
much better
okay so i just want to bring some of
this together to argue that
understanding research teams as
communities of practice is more
inclusive than disciplines right if
we're all doing the work together
alongside each other we're all learning
we're all
coming up with new ideas we're all
correcting each other and that that's
the best way to build a community
and then i hope you've seen that
incorporating diverse standpoints such
as people who have a variety of
education levels
including none at all in science
produces more comprehensive reliable
respectful and useful
knowledge
and also everyone who participates in
research contributes knowledge
and community building
and opportunities for learning so i
think we i think we're easy it's easy
for us to say yeah collaborators
contribute labor
they contribute more than that even if
it's hard for us to recognize they
absolutely do even the undergrads
sitting in the lab and telling jokes is
lifting everybody's spirits bringing
everybody more together bringing a sense
of community building
and that's really crucial to knowledge
production
and then of course this idea of
peripheral wisdom which i love that we
need outsiders to tell us when we're in
the wrong
and when we're in the right
so that if so then that takes me back to
my original question which is who then
should count as a collaborator ethically
normatively who should we consider to be
collaborators i hope the answer to this
is obvious
and that it's everybody
so then let's move back to ethical ai or
ethical research ethical science ethical
technology what does this mean in
practice what can we do
so i would contend that we can't build
ethical technology or ethical knowledge
without ethical collaborations it's the
first crucial step
and so some ways to do that are
appreciate technicians right if we pay
them more if we say thank you if we make
them authors if that's what they're
interested in being
and they're going to be more committed
they're going to stay in that lab
they're gonna work harder okay they're
gonna think more deeply about what
they're doing all of which is good for
knowledge
we should listen to undergrads
because they can be a source of
inspiration and new insights for the
rest of us
we should partner with communities
truly partner not just show up and try
to do research that we think is for
their good their own benefit right
and we can only do that through their
partnership really if we're in like a
helper role a service role
because of course we can't solve social
problems without the help of the society
we're trying to
help
all right so here's some steps here's
some practical things that i hope
participants in this innovation lab and
everybody
can do will do
to help establish ethical collaborations
as a cornerstone of collaborative
research
so first of all we need a diverse team
in every sense
okay expertise identity career stage
experience all of those things are going
to make better knowledge
there are people who have expertise who
study how best to do team science people
who belong to the the science of team
science discipline um they have a really
wonderful website called interreach
which has some resources on how to build
an effective team especially in science
um there's there's some
publications that have come out of this
movement that have sort of practical
guidelines for research teams one from
the national research council and one
from the national cancer institute
both of those are available freely
online
so my role in most of my projects has
been as the social scientist on a team
of scientists and engineers
and that is not enough
that's an important first step a lot of
funders now require a social scientist
or an ethicist to be on these large
collaborative teams
but let me tell you it's not enough one
person alone can't ensure ethical
collaboration it's too it's too hard
it's too complex
and so i would argue that instead of
having one facilitator i would train
everybody in facilitation skills okay
there's lots of webinars workshops where
you can learn how to work well with
others
rather than outsourcing it to somebody
else it's better if we all do it
together we all have skin in the game
and then finally most importantly we
need to practice
trust respect and listening actually do
it not just talk about it so here are
some ways we can do that
and one is to write a memorandum of
understanding
um this lots of teams do this sometimes
it's pretty formalized and it's deciding
things like authorship and data sharing
who is it who is the leader who is
responsible for mentoring how do we
handle complaints
um so lots of teams do this already
and we should all do it and we should
follow it and we should remember that
it's a living document that should be
updated and we should it should be a
starting point for building consensus
um throughout the life of the project
so you can google around and find
examples for these in some templates
there's something called the contributor
roles taxonomy
that i think is really helpful that lays
out all the kinds of work that are part
of scientific research and then helps
you decide
how to label a contributor so beyond my
list of you know technicians and
students and volunteers
um it breaks it down more into like data
analysts versus data creators versus
data interpreters okay and then that can
help you figure out how people in your
team fit together
um
this should be obvious but we should
respect everyone's contributions with
pay
okay i talked about volunteers a little
bit and students who sometimes work
without pay
we should pay everybody for their time
and intellectual property okay so
everybody's making an epistemic
contribution
that should be recognized and that's
going to be different in different
fields and different contributors are
going to want different kinds of
recognition so that's gonna be a
discussion among your teammates how do
how do people want to be recognized for
their contributions both of labor and of
knowledge
and there are two documents that are
based on each other and they're lovely
called the collaborators bill of light
bill of rights these are written by
scholars and digital humanities and it's
really about defining the roles of
collaborators and particularly of
student collaborators to how to and how
to avoid
exploitation
of various kinds of workers
and then of course inviting and
responding to feedback creating spaces
for open communication
is a crucial part of team science and
partly this is to inspire reflection
just like an undergrad asking a question
is going to make a grad student stop and
think through what they're doing and
that's good for the science
and
if we invite reflection among our team
members then we're all going to stop
what we're doing and make sure that what
we're doing fits what we actually want
to be doing what we should be doing
ethically and morally and epistemically
thanks
kaelin that was fantastic and it gives
us so much more to think about in
broadening
the
ethics of
biosciences so much more broadly as we
you know you talked about working with
uh you know engineering teams going to
remote locations and working with you
know local communities and indigenous
communities where and you mentioned
trust
which i think is just so important
because you know so many of these
communities have just been they've been
exploited they you know this is like
okay now there's another group of
probably predominantly white people
going to come in and tell us how you
know we should be living our lives and
they just after the umpteenth time of
this possibly over you know decades and
decades you know they're not going to be
very trustful and their people are going
to come in and take their collect their
data points and go away and never see
the results of that again so i think
that's so important and it's it's
important not only for
dealing with
indigenous peoples um you know wherever
they are alaska or or hawaii or here in
north america but also in some of our
biosample um data
communities that we go and get data from
so people with autism spectrum disorder
people with mental health disorders
people with you know other neurological
um disorders or other things we we tend
to you know they're they're sort of a
means to an end right they're going to
get us the data point we want we're
going to go ahead and write great papers
um so i think that's just so was such an
important statement and i'm
curious about your own experiences with
this what you have seen
in terms of the positive feedback you've
possibly gotten from you know the native
alaskans uh in your own work
yeah thanks i really didn't even talk
about research participants and and
indigenous
data sets are an amazing example of
potential exploitation and potential
mutual benefit
right if those data are used
appropriately respectfully
there can be a lot of good that can come
out of biomedical collaborations with
indigenous communities and kim talber is
a scholar in my field who writes about
indigenous data rights over biosamples
and it's she her arguments are fabulous
on how to do that well
and so for us we're still sort of
figuring out
how to best serve our partners in new
kayak vic and we've i told you some
examples of how they've already sort of
corrected our course thank goodness
and another project i did with
charlottesville residents is a little
maybe a better example of that which is
advocates in charlottesville are pushing
the city to build an open data portal to
share the city's data online publicly
and so i was working with them to try to
figure out what that portal should look
like and what should be on it and who
should be in charge of it
and and we came up with really different
goals between what the city wanted and
what the citizens wanted
and what people who didn't know anything
about data wanted which was me right i
have no idea how to use open data sets
and
except that i knew that they were a good
thing and so how do we make this
this object this portal work for the
city with its concerns about privacy
and its concerns about democratic
engagement right open data can be a way
to pull people in and help people
develop an argument for the need for
change and the data advocates who just
wanted all the data and wanted it now
and the rest of us who would like to
learn what we can learn from using these
kinds of projects so yeah bringing
together all those different
stakeholders
um is crucial for the success of the
research and also crucial for the
success of addressing real social
problems like infrastructure like
democratic democratic engagement like
government transparency
yeah i like that and i was also struck
by
your comments about um
inclusion of say undergraduates in the
research enterprise
and
i'm
old enough now myself to have seen a lot
of people who are older than me simply
just flat out refuse to include
undergraduates as part of you know on an
author list just you know oh they're
undergraduates you know what do they
know they were just the pair of helping
hands and so we don't need to give them
any sort of
authorship credit
and in my own life i've tried to do that
where possible because like you know
what's the harm right it's fact it's
good right it's good for that student it
like helps them and you know one of the
things you know as somebody who's sat on
a lot of graduate um uh student you know
uh admissions committees is that one of
the things we look for is paging through
their applications say how many papers
have they published and if it's you know
oh they're not supposed to or no we
don't allow them you're denying them
this wonderful you know ticket to the
research you know
ticket to entry into the research world
that uh had you just given them the
authorship it probably would have gotten
them past the door so i don't know i i'm
i'm intrigued by that and um i'm curious
if you've got any examples yourself or
you know of anybody who for example they
were included on some early paper and
now they're like you know
i don't know they're
national you know they've got some big
award or they're now you know some
superstar who had that opportunity i
don't know if that makes any sense but
uh yeah yeah no absolutely i think
that's another argument for equity and
inclusion
that if students don't have papers
they're not going to get into grad
school in engineering at least like
you're expected to have a paper when you
graduate undergrad and that's
you have to communicate that expectation
to the pi so that they'll put the
undergrads on and so that they'll
rethink that assumption about
oh undergrads don't deserve to be
authors you know or they'll plan
i've done this myself where i plan
papers that we're writing really for the
benefit of the undergrads like it's
preliminary results for example like
we're not going to finish the study
while that undergrad is a student so
let's write up something now so that
that student can be on it
and then we'll build on that paper in
the future and that's been great for me
right it forces me to get some papers
out the door
um and then that student has
proof of the like incredible
contributions that they've made and i
think a lot of people
you know i'm being a little facetious
because of course undergrads need a lot
of training just like anybody to do
research well
um but one of the most valuable things i
found about working with undergrads
is that they show up
you know every tuesday at one i'm going
to have a student in my office who's
going to look at me really eagerly and
say what am i doing this week that's
right which keeps me on target and make
sure that i've done my part so that i
don't disappoint the student and that
has actually been an incredible
boon to my own research just like the
relentlessness of it that you you want
the undergrads depending on you and so
therefore you produce
and i think only undergrads could do
that if it were a collaborator i think
we wouldn't be as
as quick you know we wouldn't we don't
meet every week with our collaborators
because we're off doing our own things
and so undergrads can provide that sort
of
pressure slash support to keep going
so absolutely absolutely and
undergraduates i've had in my labs in
various institutions um i've always
tried to give them those opportunities
either to you know present a poster at a
big conference or to you know have first
author publications on things that you
know what's the harm it's no harm to me
i'm still an author right i'm just the
you know the guy at the end of the list
right but the per the people who are
actually doing the work you know give
them that opportunity and i had one
student who i just thought the world of
um and i always tried to make sure that
she had opportunities to lead
you know the writing of papers and
whatnot um at the this was while she was
kind of an undergraduate and kind of
after she had graduated but she was
still working in the lab um
she ended up with enough
peer-reviewed publications
of herself that she was on
uh that her age index was like higher
than some of the junior faculty that we
were considering
and she's now a grad she eventually went
to grad graduate school herself and now
she's a graduate student but i always
thought you know gosh if we just were
able to do that for so many more
students that would be wonderful
right and also as a recognition of the
work that they've done yeah just to help
their career but to like say thank you
you know they earned that
absolutely and so
one of the things about the i guess
bringing this back to ethical ai is is
as we're thinking about you know we
collect this data and we use it to build
models and then presumably we want to
make predictions about like i don't know
where permafrost is melting more quickly
or what what have you and you're using
computational models on that how do some
of these ethical
considerations map themselves if they do
it all into you know
turning these things into code or into
mathematical models do you have any
sense about that
yeah i do and i think ethically ai is
is scary because we think it's so
technical we got so so focused on the
math and the coding and the models and
the predictive aspects and
it's easy to just say just build the
thing and we'll figure out who's
responsible for it later we'll figure
out what your contribution was later you
know we'll figure out how we're going to
share this later and that's really
dangerous that's a way to exploit
particularly junior research members
and
you know underrepresented minorities are
going to bear the brunt of that
discrimination
and so it worries me about ethical ai
that
it's it's so people think of it as being
so technical and it's not like it's
still a team of people working together
to build this thing and so we need to
respect that team
as a sort of living breathing organism
that we need to sustain and support and
create governance structure for
and provide training and mentor you know
what i mean like all these things there
has to be so much learning
on a team of people working on ethical
ai because it relies on so many
disciplines and so many kinds of
knowledge
um
so yeah i gave this talk bringing
together a wide variety of fields on
purpose to make the point that i think
these these recommendations i'm making
are true for any field of research or
design
well you've certainly touched on one of
the main thrusts of our biomedical data
science innovation lab is to bring these
different voices together with different
points of view and different
perspectives different backgrounds
different kind of
sets of you know skill sets that they
can bring together because you know so
often
how many times have we seen something
where i don't know a bunch of people
just cut from the same cloth get
together and do something and then say
hey everybody look what we built you
should all want to use this or whatever
it is and peop people who are not within
that you mentioned kind of the outsiders
right we'll take a look at it and go i
would never have done it that way and
what you've created is completely
useless to me if you had my input i
might have been able to give you some
different you know more nuanced
understanding of this area and so anyway
bringing all these different voices
together is is
such an important element of of research
of ethical ai and certainly part of our
biomedical data science innovation
i'm so glad
yes
well um
i think we're
about done caitlin wiley from university
of virginia thank you so much for
sharing your uh insights and wisdom and
uh ideas about team science and
collaboration and what all that means
for ethical ai we really appreciate it
thank you thank you everybody for for
joining us and uh